you know one of the things I get that is
interesting to me is people are afraid
about their retirement now that's not
interesting to me it's just a fact but
what's it the interesting part about it
is people will call me up and they'll
say you know as old as I am
I'm you know is it too late for me well
how old are you 32 you know like what I
got socks older than that I mean really
it's not too late people have this man
I'm 50 it's almost over I'm 50 it's
almost over you know and and they're
freaking out as if they can't go win
with retirement they won't be able to
retire with dignity because they've
waited so late now it's very important
that you get yourself out of that get
yourself on a plan build an emergency
fund so that you can save for retirement
and save for your kids college and do
some investing build some wealth so you
can retire with dignity that's very
important so when we talk about around
here all the time and you'll be able to
give without rageous generosity when you
do all of that so it's very very
important that you be thinking that way
but this sense that it's too late am I
too old to save money not if you're
still sucking wind it's not too late I
so I'm talking to you if you're feeling
like you're too bold to save money your
odds Ronald Reagan was president in the
United States he started at 70 his
eight-year term was age 70 to 78 it's
not - you're not - oh it's not too late
I mean at 76 years old
he stood at the Berlin Wall and said to
Gorbachev tear this wall down he was 76
years old at age 70 Benjamin Franklin
helped to draft a little document called
the Declaration of Independence he was
70 years old John Glenn became the
oldest person to go into space at age 77
Grandma Moses never painted a painting
until she was almost 82 she did 1,500
works of art several hundred of which
she did after age 100 Albert Schweitzer
ran a hospital in Africa at 89 years old
Colonel Sanders started Kentucky Fried
Chicken at 67 years old so it's not
you're not dying until you quit we got
this idea that you know I'm gonna retire
early at 55 I'm gonna do nothing for the
next 40 freakin years
that's dumb you need to do something
this planet needs your ideas it needs
your creativity it needs the inventions
and the books and the songs that are
stuck in your brain let them out let
them out so it's not too late and if
you're worried about retirement go get
Chris Hogan's book retire inspired it'll
walk you with a clear plan right through
it but it's not too late it's not too
late you're not too old those people
thought didn't think they were too old
I mean if Benjamin Franklin helped write
the Declaration of Independence at age
70 you can still do something at age 55
okay no whining aloud you got to go do
it really I mean this is don't you I'm
good no you're not out it's in your
brain it's in your brain in your mind so
make a decision that yes I have to take
some serious steps to get my finances
under control or I'm gonna be eating dog
food at retirement but make a decision
to take those steps
don't sit go well it's too late it's too
late now I'm stuck it's not too late it
is not too late for you hey you guys
Rachel crews here hope you are enjoying
the Dave Ramsey show if you didn't know
I actually have my own
YouTube channel so I do videos twice a
week on life and money so you can click
the subscribe button to subscribe to my
channel and if you want to check out our
video right now check out the video on
how to make a budget